aquí estamos en la comunidad indígena
lenca tierra del padre
con machetes en mano los indígenas
lencas buscan infundir respeto contra
una posible invasión de las autoridades
locales en su comunidad
ya el juzgado o la corte suprema ha
mandado a desalojar una demanda que ha
prosperado por parte de un terrateniente
este terrateniente es de afiliación del
gobierno actual los lencas uno de los
siete pueblos nativos del territorio
hondureño denuncia una persecución
política para expropiar los de sus
tierras el pueblo unido jamás
120 familias cargan a cuestas una orden
judicial de desalojo de las más de 350
hectáreas donde viven y cultivan sus
alimentos
aquí tengo plátano macho y tengo
frijoles también el maíz es el caso de
pedro canales quien siembra sus parcelas
para alimentar a su familia y vender el
resto en los mercados una economía que
está en peligro pues supuestamente nos
dijeron que quieren hacer unos
condominios para gente de dinero
y a nosotros pues desplazarnos verdad de
nuestra tierra tierras que han heredado
de sus ancestros desde el siglo 18 y que
planean heredarles a sus hijos
en orden y orden
también pretenden pasar a nuevas
generaciones la lengua autóctona que se
encarga de enseñar la profesora grimilda
henestrosa una dos tres
[Música]
me dan a pesar que ellos se vayan
porque no tenemos para dónde irnos
y de amor a la calle
el tiempo corre en contra esta comunidad
indígena cuya orden de desalojo debía
cumplirse los primeros días de noviembre
la idea es resistir pacíficamente para
preservar sus territorios